it's the third explosion in less than 24
hours in northern Syria an early morning
car bong in tilapia shows the area
remains dangerous the district is now
under the control of Turkish backed
fighters who took it from Kurdish forces
it's part of the 30 kilometer safe zone
which turkey wants to establish on the
border it shares with Syria the Syrian
National Army a group of Fighters backed
by Turkey say there would have been more
casualties if the blast had happened
during rush hour the car exploded and we
had a lot of wounded and we brought them
to the hospital the area here is for
civilians there are shops here and a
working bakery turkey says it's defused
hundreds of homemade bombs and mines in
the areas it cleared and its military
denies allegations by Kurdish fighters
are advancing in three villages outside
the ceasefire zone Kurdish forces have
asked Western allies including the u.s.
to stop what they call Turkey's
ceasefire violations in a change of tone
the Kurds military commander has thanked
both the Russian and US presidents and
assured them of support despite the fact
that the two governments are on opposing
sides of the Syrian conflict
and as US senators reiterated their
support for the Kurdish commander the
Turkish president has warned them
against what he calls sitting down with
terrorists
reject a Oberto on also criticized NATO
allies for not standing with him against
a group the Alliance itself recognizes
as a terrorist organization
currently our Army in the Syrian
National Army are combing every inch of
the area under our control and clearing
traps but if they come across any
terrorists in this area it is our
natural right to crush them it is so in
writing under the deal reached between
Russia and Turkey Russian troops have
been patrolling more areas in the
Northeast Moscow is sending hundreds of
more troops to police the new territory
it's taken on behalf of the Assad
government Russia's Defense Ministry
says it will be establishing 15 security
posts along the border which will be run
by Syrian government forces as the clock
ticks down on the six-day hiatus between
Turkey and Russia both countries have
warned Kurdish fighters to withdraw
within 30 kilometers inside Syrian
territory Moscow says the patrol has
already begun and as battle lines become
drawn and redrawn millions of Syrians
hold their breath as Arabs and Kurds
they are waiting for peace to come to
these areas so they can return home sama
Punjabi the al-jazeera are chuckling on
the turkey-syria border